i believe in believing in people more
than they sometimes believe in
themselves and that means
pushing them and that means pushing
what's capable
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is the fascinating
funny uh secretive
mysterious uh deep humble
and um honorable dave castro
he's the co-director of training and the
games director for crossfit
he's somebody that i met years back
after getting into crossfit and going to
the crossfit games
um we just you know we we had a really
really good deep conversation he's one
of those guys
that you don't always know a ton about
and he's really private and some of that
comes from
uh you know just the type of person that
he is but also being a navy seal which
is something that some people don't even
know but he he really
opened up today about you know his
thoughts and his feelings and how
the whole thing is gone with the boom of
crossfit and
um opinions about him that have not
always been
positive and um
and of course just how he operates as a
human like just how he's doing during
lockdown and how he feels and
don't worry crossfit fans we also get to
hear about what might happen
for the 2020 games dave thank
you so much for doing the show
yeah no problem so you're in la right
now i am
yeah yep okay not so bad here
is it it's not in europe right yeah
near aromas yeah what's how are you
good the uh the craziness has been uh
it's been an easy adjustment for me
because my routine pre-this
has not changed much after this all
started
i'd start my day here at my house and
i'd do work do crossfit work
sometimes work out first and then go to
the ranch do stuff at the ranch
and then come back and just bounce back
and forth between the two locations
well with these with the um everything
that's going on i'm still able to
maintain that same
type of routine so i'm still starting my
day up at the house and going over to
the ranch doing some stuff there
shooting programming cleaning up feeding
my mule
feeding my pigs taking my dog on a hike
so it's been it's been it's been an easy
adjustment for me
except for what's going on for everyone
else and all the stuff in crossfit
we've had to cancel a lot of seminars uh
there's a lot of stuff going on with the
games so
you know we have we have a lot we're
dealing with but um that stuff's all
been hard
but as far as my personal routine it's
been uh
it's been pretty good hmm i can really
i like it yeah i mean i so one of the
things that i've
really realized i kind of maybe knew
this before but i i'm an introvert
like i like being home do does that
resonate with you
oh yeah for sure i mean i you know
everyone's like oh i missed my gym i
wish i could go work out with my peep
and i'm like i just work out in my
garage and i'd like it that way
i have no gym that i uh go to or train
at so
working out by myself is is uh my
preferred
way of training well that
i mean that's what we see in your videos
on social is you're working out in the
gym and you're in your own gym is it
in your garage like are you yeah no
right now i'm in my office
uh one of the bedrooms of our house i
converted into an office
um i just just did work out my gym is in
we have a three-car garage and
i converted one of the bays into a gym
i've only lived here for a couple years
now because i was living in san diego
for about
10 or 12 years and so there was a lot of
upgrades and improvements we need to
make on the house so i could have my gym
and i could have my office
this was a bedroom that i converted into
my office but it works well
so um and i don't work out often at the
ranch sometimes i do but but not often
you don't want to do more do you have a
do you have a rig in the house then
like in yeah in the garage i have a nice
little rig
the only thing i can't really do here is
rope climbs and i like to rope climb
so if i do go to the ranch and work out
i'll usually run the hill and do some
rope climbs or something like that
that you can't do at home yeah exactly
yeah
that's how i usually do it too i try and
spread out like what can i do right now
so if i'm gonna take a trip i'm like
i'm gonna lift because i know when i
travel and go to a gym somewhere and
wherever
yeah exactly they have olympic bars you
know they're probably gonna have plates
so i try and cram it in yeah
i do the same when i travel i so i do
basically exactly the same do the things
i can do here that i can't do on the
road and then on the road i'm doing a
lot of bodyweight stuff
and a lot of running and you know hotel
gyms have the
bicycles or the treadmills so
on the road you just make it work with
what you have
do you love i mean look
i mean you're i had to look up your
title because i was like
i mean all i think of you was like
games puppet master um but co-director
of training
and games director for crossfit yes yeah
so the training role is my most
significant role i would say in crossfit
because it's uh i schedule and staff and
oversee our training department with
nicole carroll who you've met
and that the the significance of that
department is huge in that we're
training all the trainers who become uh
who open up crossfit gyms and who spread
the word across it to the world
that's what i've been doing longer than
i've been doing the games i started
doing that with greg and nicole back in
2006. so and that that
role keeps me behind the scenes and i'm
you know i don't get a lot of uh
attention for that role all the
attention i get is for the game stuff
obviously
and um like cornrows
i know like you put on a show yeah
i know i miss it too um so we uh
so the training that consumes more of my
time actually throughout the year
because it's a year-round
it's a year-round department we're
always doing seminars
and then the games is obviously very
important and i have a significant role
in that
but we have a good team um we have a lot
of people who work on that
project and it's not especially now
without regionals or the uh
the open announcements it's not as much
um traveling and
you know we can just focus on creating
the open workouts and then
creating the games which is nice which
is actually pretty cool
so how much did you use to travel and
how much do you travel now because you
said it's not much different right now
what's going on
with having to be at home all the time
and i just remember seeing you
all over the place at boxes everywhere
and so
me it feels like you have normally
traveled a lot so
what's the old and what's the new track
well when we did
when we would do um the open
announcements that was five weeks out of
the year that
i was on the road and then you add the
regionals another three or four weeks
so that was ten weeks of travel just for
those two different events
and every time i did those i would also
try to go to as many boxes as i could in
the local areas
just to support the gyms and not to to
do anything else
but other than just to say hi just to
say hello to the gym members and the gym
owners
specifically but without those two i'm
doing less travel if i don't have to
travel
i don't want to travel i don't like
traveling at all
but there's still a lot of other things
i have to travel for with crossfit
sometimes we'll have some meetings with
greg somewhere or there's something
going on in you know
boston or so there's still travel i do
that's not
let's say high profile travel but um but
that's business essential travel
obviously none of that's happening right
now which is nice because again like i
don't really like to travel
it's uh i spent my you know when i uh
after i graduated high school i listed
in the navy
spent 12 years in the navy traveled a
ton there
then when i transitioned out of the navy
and worked full-time for crossfit
i was teaching the seminars and
traveling every weekend for years
and so i've traveled my whole life and i
imagine you can
you can relate now that i don't have to
travel as much i don't want to travel as
much
yeah i agree i
ask you what's it like after racing and
you
i mean like i'm i love being able to
stay home i love having more of a
routine
and i love being able to do something on
a weekend so there's so many things
about
not traveling that is really nice
because you can choose when you want to
or not yeah and having a routine and a
weekend is
really nice especially as we get older
and just like you want to
slow down a little i don't know if you
can relate to slowing down being a
former
race car driver
yes people ask all the time well what
are you doing now and i'm like
well i'm and so you get you get like
pulled into it you're like well i'm
doing this i'm doing that and then i
remember
and i'm trying to do less like i
want to do less yes
i feel the same way but sometimes it's
hard right
what what what part of that's hard um
if you have a lot of responsibilities
doing lessons sometimes
sometimes it's hard if you can't yes i
have a lot of responsibilities and
sometimes i'd like to do less
but they're my responsibilities and i
have to uh
have to do them even with the games and
stuff like that i mean that there's a
lot around that where it's like damn
this is a lot of work i wish there was
um sometimes a little
uh less of it i needed to do but it's
it's good
so then i enjoy it do you like to cook
i don't like to cook at all my wife
loves to cook she does all the cooking
and
she she's really good at it and so i
don't
and she doesn't want me in the kitchen
at all so i stay completely away from
she gets mad whenever i go in the
kitchen
so we've been together for you know
almost 20 years
so i haven't and she's always been a
really good cook and she's always
not wanting me in the kitchen so i've
never so like the last 20 years i
haven't
had to do much cooking or any at all
champagne problems so do you clean
you don't not really uh
maybe a little um but not
again you know she she she cleans she
has a
more detailed process in cleaning than i
do so
she doesn't want me to clean well
oftentimes she might disagree with me on
that she might just think
i do it uh i don't do it effectively
as long as you show your appreciation
for cooking and cleaning and doing that
whole thing
and that's how i feel it's like if you
get a little appreciation you're like
i'm happy to do it no problem
yeah yeah i try to i try to uh
give her all the love and appreciation i
can for what she does
i think i do at least talking about
obviously travel and work and everything
in the games and
i mean what like what the hell is going
on
with which part well i mean there's a
lot of parts to it right because
obviously we don't know what the
situation is going to be if we're going
to be able to be in large crowds
will that happen will that ever happen i
mean this is a question aaron and i were
talking about last night with a friend
what if that's the thing of the past i
mean we don't know
that yet um so there's there's obviously
the games itself
then there's like i think about it and i
think about just how much preparation
goes into
being ready for it and i would imagine a
lot of athletes are probably in their
final phases of like preparing for the
games and
being ready conditioning wise and so
i mean a lot of them are going to have
access to either their own gym
or a great gym at their house but it's
still not the same
right it's still not that same you're
not doing it with people as much and
you might not have a rope in your garage
and
things like that so there's just i would
think that there's
from my little like lack of a lack of
total understanding
mind goes there's a lot that goes into
this and giving them
their chance to be ready as well as just
when could that even be
you know what's interesting about the
athletes in our sport is uh especially
when you look at people like
let's take throning as an example and
and most of them
they you look at traditional sports like
let's say football
like aaron's sport they have an off
season and those guys in the off season
they're taking it off and they're not
out at the field practice some are i
imagine but they're not all throwing
footballs every day and
and running routes every day but our
sport
our athletes it's it's like it's their
lifestyle
they're most of them are training all
year round uh
frazier says he takes like two weeks off
after the games
but i think he still trains you know a
little but so they're
i think they're mostly always at a
pretty high state of readiness
so if we're to do the games in august
even in this
unique environment i believe most of
them will be
as ready as they possibly could be minus
you know having some access to as you
were saying
some of the specialty items they might
have in their gym but a lot of these
guys at that level
have really good home setups they kind
of have to because it's their livelihood
and so um let's say let's take a couple
scenarios let's say
we were able to do the games in august
um
i think they're still preparing and i
think they would be
as prepared as they need to be for that
event let's say we need to push it out
just
you know later in the year i then think
um
they'll still be prepared because it's
just the way they they um
they train they're just always and at
that level if you're
if you know you're going to the games or
capable of going to the games
why wouldn't you just stay sharp for the
whole year while we
figure out what we're going to do we're
also but you kind of mentioned
something um crowds we're also looking
into options where we do stuff where
there
is not where we don't have crowds so
that's on the table
where we do have a games but we don't
have any fans there
for a reduced field yeah exactly
but check it out we'd still stream it
and we'd still show it to the world
so it'd still be something exciting that
the community could come behind
if we were not able to have fans because
it is a crazy time i
i believe everything's gonna return to
normal eventually i hope so
but in this current climate um we have
to look at options like that
in terms of doing it with no fans and
again
you know so let's say when we do it in
madison let's say
around 20 000 people go um so those
20 000 can't be there but hundreds of
thousands watch it
from home and so i think we could even
be more powerful
if we were to do it that way and just
find the fittest alive with the reduce
field event that
has no spectators to accommodate the
current climate
yet stream it to the world and make a
great produce a great show and
but even in that there's going to be
sacrifices meaning you know it won't be
identical to how it was in madison if we
did something like i'm talking about
there
um things will look very different again
maybe a reduced field maybe certain
aspects of the competition
aren't even happening those are all
things that are on the table and we're
talking about
to accommodate uh trying to find the
fittest man fittest woman
alive in 2020. i think we can do it
you know i was really bummed and uh i
was really bummed with the dana white
thing with the ufc thing
that was so excited did you follow that
at all
they were so dana white got an island
and he was gonna start doing fights
there this weekend yeah exactly
they were building out a ufc uh ufc
venue
to host ufc fights starting i guess this
weekend yeah the 18th and 19th
and everyone was excited they had a
fight card
and it'd be cool to see some sort of
sports to have something back
but at the last minute disney his big
bosses came in and said no you're not
going to do it
so it got it got cancelled but i was
really excited at the notion of him
being the guy who uh
because he's kind of on the fringe of
traditional sports and on the fringe of
traditional sports making decisions so i
thought it would be really cool
if he pulled something off so at this
point i almost feel that way about us
well you know they could
pull something off and august is you
know a lot will be
it'll be very different by august but
hopefully we can do something in august
something in that same time frame of the
games to uh
to to make to find the fittest man and
woman alive
[Music]
i mean will your programming
i mean like will the programming be
affected at all programming is
definitely something i'm curious about
with you because
you know yeah for sure well here here's
what we'll dictate
here's what will guide the programming
where we do it so if we do this like if
we do this
it might not even end up being in
madison no
what no hay bales yeah well it depends
where it depends where we go
so um the programming especially for the
games and events like that
really flow off of where the events
happening at and
what kind of uh terrain we have and what
resources and what the natural
environment is
around it so once we
what was that what are the options
there's a few
there's a few on the uh on the table
that i'm not ready to get into
but that would uh i mean i heard you
think thailand and you
got excited so people we're not to do an
island that's a little that's probably
beyond our means dana white in the ufc
can pull that off
we're not there right now um
so we'll see no but we have some good
options we have some we have a good um
potential plan in place that we might
try to activate on
and if we did the programming would be
very suited to that
to that plan and that location is there
any chance that it's back at the ranch
we have a few plans we have a few plans
in place
and we're looking at all possibilities i
mean but it makes sense because you
can't have a correct i mean
there's really no space for a crowd
there anyway correct exactly if we were
to do something at the ranch
there would be uh it would it let's okay
so let's say let's play your
idea out of the ranch if we were to
still do it in madison where it's
looking like we can't anyways because of
what they have going on
it would be hard to justify not having
fans
in terms of they have all the facilities
let's say we did do something at the
ranch instead
well guess what we can easily justify
not having any fans because there's
it's not big enough there's not the
infrastructure there there's not
um we couldn't we've done events there
before where we had
fans and it was just bulging out of
scenes it was there's
it doesn't work well
which it's cool i mean yeah you did your
level one there
yeah i was lucky enough to do the level
one there and saw you and you took my
sister and i on a little tour around the
property because it's your family's
property
yep yep yeah i mean it's a cool place
and obviously
i can see how that would drive the
programming because there's everything
from like
running up hills to shooting
right i mean yeah yeah i mean you're i
mean you shoot
i shoot a lot and because of my
experience with competitive shooting and
shooting
i can be the first to say i'd never have
shooting in the games just because it's
not a test and a measure of fitness it's
like
so far now here's the thing there's cool
events and one-offs and like sideshows
but not at the crossfit games so there's
cool places for that
combining crossfit and shooting but at
the crossfit games where our charter is
to find the fittest man and woman alive
it doesn't really make sense especially
when you look at half the field is
usually international and
a lot of places around the world don't
have gun friendly laws like we do
so people just have less access to
firearms
um so it wouldn't be you know
matt frazier is a pretty good shooter so
he would have just
give him another advantage over the
field huge advantage that everyone else
doesn't have
do you um like do you become friends
with some of
the crossfitters i mean yeah for sure i
think uh
i become friends and sometimes they get
mad at me brooke wells is really mad at
me right now
she because of last year what happened
at the games and i
uh said something in the press
conference because i considered us
pretty good friends and i said uh
i made a comment about the stepping on
the line thing and how
i thought uh she made a comment about it
and then i made a comment in a press
conference after the games
in response to her comment and it really
upset her and so
we we uh we kind of used to talk on a
regular basis but we haven't talked
since then until recently until the
documentary came out this new
documentary
and she just she sent me a message
saying thanks for um
saying that you know you didn't want
that to happen to me or something like
that
but um so so some of them sometimes get
really upset at me
and you know the thing is like i'd say
this about that brook situation it was
nothing
what happened at the games and even what
i said in the press conference was not
nothing personal it's just all
it's it's what i'm doing there and it's
who i am there
you know i have to be i can't be
everybody's buddy after games and i
can't be on
anyone's side really because of the role
i'm in
but yeah you know some of them over the
years because of the multiple events we
do and the time we spend together
i developed friendship with i'd say
people like uh
josh bridges especially the earlier
athletes because it seems like we did a
lot more stuff together
back then josh and you know i put him
through training when
we were both in the navy at the same
time together and
yeah he was coming through training and
i was an instructor
and so i met him through that and uh
this was before he ever went to the
games
so people like that rich froney i'd
consider him a pretty good friend
uh dan dan bailey even though i give him
a lot of
[ __ ] and and obviously i become better
friends with the guys
than i do a lot of female athletes but i
do become a
you know i am a friend with with a
handful of them too
so yes and i would say over the years
with the new format
and that that i travel less to that we
don't have the open announcements that
we don't have the
regionals we don't have the invitational
where we used to take the best athletes
those were all opportunities that we
hung out
and spent time together those are all
gone and i don't travel to these
sectional
the sanctioned events so the only time i
really see them now is at the games so
that with the modern
era not i'm not as close with the modern
era of athlete the
previous era of athlete and the previous
era it was interesting because a lot of
them would also
be on our training team our seminar team
so
you know for um like camille i'd
consider her a good friend
camille's on was on the training team
rich croning was on the training team
margo alvarez so a lot of these people
who you know from the last generation
who were stars
did both they were great athletes and
great trainers
you don't see that as much now these a
lot of the the newer generation are just
focusing on competing and don't
most of mark trainers it seems and they
don't um
they don't try out for the seminar team
so less opportunities for me to
have a connection with some of them than
there was in the past
and also at this stage too um that that
last group you know that was
um i think what's happening even maybe
in my own mind
so you know we've been doing the games
for 12 years that earlier group i was
talking about i was
10 years younger you know closer to
their age they were 25
i was 32 so a little more you know
relatable in age and now
these athletes are 24 25 and i'm 42.
so i'm also you know the gap and what we
have in common is increasing
so you keep getting older and they keep
getting younger
yeah exactly that's literally happening
well 19 even some of them are like
i know it's crazy i'm old enough to be
some
a lot of the parents most of them not
most but a handful
which is wild do you ever use the
athletes
at all in the programming process for
um either to bounce something off of
or to ever test a workout or try to just
get some like feedback on or
even just some advice at some point like
hey
asking about anything going on or what
just any thoughts is there any
yeah for sure so but like when we're
when i'm making the workouts for the
games
i'll use athletes who didn't qualify or
any stage really but i'll use athletes
who didn't qualify for the games who are
really good
to help me test workouts and um and i'll
and they give me feedback and i
but usually in that environment it's the
visual i see how
the the workout looks how they feel
after it
and then from that i'm able to make um
adjustments and
their feedback on like well that was one
of the worst things i've ever done you
know
that's like okay that's what i'm looking
for yeah or maybe they'll say
sometimes you'll say oh that wasn't so
bad and it's like okay what can i do
to make it harder but so yes i do
and and throughout the years it's been a
number of different athletes some have
been more involved than others because
i use a lot of when i was living in
southern california i used a lot of guys
from down there
again who didn't qualify to the games
people like rich
throughout the years i've used him i've
shot him ideas or i've shot him
events to test and he'll test in the
privacy of his own gym and send me
feedback or send me
how he did his times um people like dan
bailey
even josh i've used josh so yes i do do
that and it's
important to the whole process every one
of these events that we do at the games
we've tested multiple times some of them
have gone through like nine or ten
iterations of testing and sometimes the
same athlete tests them over and over
and over
so i can compare the times and see yeah
it's brutal some of these guys i feel
for no
yeah it is hell and sometimes when they
get the invite to contest i'll invite
them to come test for a week
they know they're coming out for just a
beat down
there's something that my saying is if
you do any workout right
you'll never want to do it again yeah
yeah
that's that's pretty accurate what's
your
favorite workout well my favorite
workout
well i think fran's my favorite but not
to do
like i'd never want to do fran because
it's so nasty and it hurts so much but i
think that's a um
that's what everyone should do and i
probably haven't done it in years
literally because it's it hurts you know
259 thrusters and pull-ups
it's not enjoyable but my favorite type
of thing to do
is i like to deadlift i just deadlifted
today because i'm okay at it
and i actually i like pull-ups
i like running i like
just um pure crossfit workouts that are
couplets and triplets just really easy
combinations but that hurt
if you push hard enough and i also don't
have a problem with crossfit and with
crossfit workouts
to not hurt like meaning i can go 60 or
70
on a workout and be
completely happy with it and now at this
stage in my life
sometimes i feel like i have to do that
more often because i get so sore so
often
it stays sore longer and so for me
moderating yeah pulling back on the
intensity
is is critical for being able to keep
working out over and over and over and
just
and i'm also only a one a day type of
guy i just do one thing i'm not doing
multiple
workouts or multiple sessions
i also program for myself and i'll just
oftentimes i come up with workouts on
the fly i don't follow any program or i
don't have any
grand plan although right now i am
trying to focus on increasing my
deadlift so i'm dead lifting more often
i also like to run i do and here's the
thing about running
one of the reasons i like to run and i
run a lot when i'm programming for the
games and really in the process
because i can think when i run yep
exactly and the reason you can think
when you run is because you're running
slow
if you run really fast you're not able
to think
that's the problem with crossfit
workouts you can't do crossfit workouts
slow
and zone out even doing them slow they
still hurt
so when doing and plus doing a crossfit
workout too slow
just prolongs the pain so when i do
crossfit workouts i'm not able to think
about other things
but if i when i run i'm able to just
kind of zone out and
think about the programming think about
what else i'm doing for the day
get creative and i think i think when i
run i'm able to be creative i'm like in
a creative
area creative zone so um
but that's running slow and comfortable
and that really helps to not have to
count reps because even let's say it was
like
let's say you know something i like the
other day i did like a hundred burpee
box jumps just as a finisher and
you just think a hundred burpee box
jumps it's the same thing over and over
again
but you gotta count yeah that's a great
point that's a really good point
what size box did you use because you're
small yeah
20. that's good that's really good
you know it's a good 10 minute finisher
for you for me that would take that
would take a
no that's that's tough that's a good one
i'm super curious
um about programming
i love for me it's such a i love it it's
creative i mean
yeah you tell me about your process
well see so programming for something
like for an individual workout is way
different
than programming for like the games
because when you program for an event
like the games
it's really like three-dimensional and i
mean that in terms of you can do
let's take fran as an example or let's
take your hundred burpee box jumps as an
example
in your gym and anyone in training is
gonna do a hundred burpee box jumps and
you're gonna set up a box and you're
gonna do
100 right there but the visual of the
games and to show the actual
race well let's think how we can advance
this down the floor
and so yeah exactly so are we going to
have them advance the box
every five reps are we going to have
them advance the box every 10 reps
are we going to have them go up and over
up and over then advance
also are we going to have at the games
we might have 10 boxes
so they do 10 here 10 here 10 here
instead of advancing their box
so those are all the type of thing
things we think about
for the games and the creative and the
visual of it
um that's the type of thing you would
never think about for your gym or
on your own when you're working out by
yourself or if you're programming for a
gym because that doesn't that doesn't
matter you're just keeping track of your
rap
reps so that's the type of thing that
makes the games uh programming
creative and and uh like i s
what i like to say three-dimensional
because there's so many different
there's the visual of it
there's the stimulus on the athlete how
it affects them
there's the actual test how it plays out
in the grand
scheme of things and also with the games
was really important and i
this is also important for regular
programming but especially for the games
none of them are stand-alone they all
tied to the rest of the weekend or the
rest of the day
or the rest of the event they all play a
piece
in that they're all interconnected so
they have to
balance yeah essentially you're saying
for sure tasks time yeah absolutely
short workout long workout heavy workout
light workout um
pushing pulling and and
usually with the games they'll be what i
call an anchor event or two
going into programming for the games i
have this one
idea that is like okay this is going to
be in the games and then everything kind
of builds around it
and so like murph in years past has been
the first year we did murph
it was an anchor event we knew we were
going to do murph and so at that point
you have you know 100 pull-ups 200 air
squats 300 push-ups
and mile runs on each side um other
events throughout the weekend
aren't going to have a lot of pull-ups
right because that that is there
and so everything else is built now that
being said with that there
so we need deadlifts for sure so you can
start to fill in the gaps of what should
happen
because that anchor piece is there and
each year
the anchor uh events are are
very different at different stages of
the weekend
and just fill in backfill from there
essentially
and make everything talk and have a
in my eyes the cohesive storyline to
them
i get a lot of heat especially this last
year a lot of a lot of people
i got a lot of heat over the programming
there was um
six events last year at the games and
after each event there was cuts
so after the first event we went from
like 150 to 75 people
then it went from like 75 to 50 and all
the way down to
at event six there we went from 20 to 10
and uh event six was a sprint
well interestingly people call that the
cut event because
they say that that was the fine the cut
event to take the field from 20 to 10.
the truth of the matter is is it was not
the cut event
the scores from all the previous five
events played a significant role
in that one event that was one sick that
was one piece of it all
it would be a cut event if the scoring
went to zero
and there was 20 people and and that
event dictated who went on to the next
one
but that wasn't the case and
interestingly if that was the case
matt frazier wouldn't have advanced and
if matt frazier wouldn't have advanced
that there would have been yeah if matt
frazier wouldn't have advanced there
would have been a flaw
with that whole thing but the reason he
was able to advance was because of the
work he put
on the previous five events and that
that was the thing there was there were
six events
to get you to ten athletes and some
athletes signed
matt tia and others struggle
and when i say struggled i mean didn't
do well enough on all the events
not just one event you know you have a
bad sprint event but how'd you do on
everything else
that's what you need to look at so i
take a lot of heat for that stuff
people like to [ __ ] yes people like the
baby you
get the blame and this is something i've
been really curious about because you
were a navy seal you got
and you got into crossfit then you know
it started with
this you know woodstock event
basically or coined a woodstock fun
fitness event at in aromas at the ranch
for the very first game
yep yep and then from there this thing
just
i mean yeah how could anyone have seen
the explosion
and so how are you
like how was that for you personally
well it's been interesting because so
when i got involved with crossfit from
being a seal
um i was not in this like okay i'm going
to become
like my goal is in crossfit to become a
little figure
a little uh character or someone who's
the face of that was
never by design it kind of just evolved
and grew
because we did a lot of media and as
that grew i saw a lot of people like me
and a lot of people didn't like me
and um it was interesting again because
you know being a seal all of our stuff
was not a seal nowadays it's a seal
nowadays it's like you of course you're
writing a book and
you're you you have podcasts and you're
you're
promoting yourself as a former seal i'm
not a huge fan of that but anyways
that's a different topic
um so back then i was not like hey i
want to come out and
try to become famous off of this
crossfit thing i just wanted to do a
good job and
and support crossfit and and work hard
and so there was a time where i started
getting a lot of hate early on
and i started getting more hate so at a
certain point and as as
becoming more popular in crossfit and
that's the other thing too i always say
yeah i'm very popular in crossfit and i
always tell people like people will say
like oh you're celebrity i'm like no i'm
not i'm just
i'm a popular figure in this thing
called crossfit and i really understand
and respect that
and um but even in that there's a lot of
people
in crossfit who still will come at me
and and
take shots at me so early on i just i
saw it and i'd read read the comments or
look at the post
and i knew it wasn't healthy and i knew
it wasn't a good thing
so then i just shut it off in my mind
i'm like all right it doesn't matter
people are gonna talk
i don't need to get involved with it i
don't need to go down this route of uh
listening to it and so for years even
before i got on social
media people um people were coming at me
so i started ignoring it then once i got
on social media it
makes you put you out there a little
more and
it would come on my channels and in the
beginning for the first couple years of
being on instagram
i just ignored it um and oftentimes when
i do these posts where i get
hundreds and hundreds of comments i stop
looking after like the first page
just because i don't want to get
consumed with all the comments
then there was a point where i was like
okay if someone says something about me
on my page i'm gonna block them i block
the [ __ ] out of people
i block so many people i've locked so
many people on my page you could just
say something about my
you could say something rude about my
hair and i'll block you
and so um so if i see it
because i don't always see them but if i
see it on my page
i block people um and that's just my way
of having a little victory over those
[ __ ] or the people who
who are petty like that because here's
the thing i look at how i conduct myself
and i'm not going to any other site or
any person's page
and talking about them or saying
anything about them
or you know like so why why do that to
me or why do that to us or why do that
to people
it baffles me um but
i also understand too i got to keep this
in perspective
oftentimes it's the vocal minority
meaning there's still a large cohort of
people who like support
and appreciate what i do in crossfit and
so i've i have to i have to really keep
them in mind and not let the vocal
minority
overwhelm me and my feelings towards
things
because of uh because they're just the
chatter is so loud
still has it still gets you every now
and again it does me every now and again
especially there's that little like
there's that little narrow lane of like
maybe i shouldn't shouldn't have done
maybe i you know and then if somebody
says something you're like
it kind of sits in there and you're like
[ __ ] yeah exactly
i uh yeah it happens but i try to move
on from it quickly
um you know there was a phase though i'd
say there was a phase when i was really
the bad guy and most things associated
with me were
it felt towards me negative then there
was a phase where i became like
um a fan favorite almost especially
especially in the last four or five
years i felt like the community was
really like
behind me and supportive i felt like i
wasn't doing enough
not that i try but enough to get more
haters
and then i think uh recently though with
this last year's programming
that kind of tipped the scales back
towards
especially when i was doing all the open
announcements and all that stuff people
really liked me i mean people would rip
on me about those but
about the presentation or whatever but
that was all in fun but i felt like then
i was a really positive
in a lot of people like i didn't get a
lot as much hate than
but with this last year's programming i
felt like it all ramped up again
and it's okay you know but it's also
it's also a sign of like
the passion of some i think it is maybe
a little it's a sign of the passion
of this fans for the sport i mean you
guys see that in nascar right there's
some crazy
that's a great i mean that's what i
ended up believing was i was like you
know what
i think the perfect balance when you
have a big enough fan base which you do
i mean you are famous um and you're
especially famous of course in crossfit
and when you have a fan base that's like
i
i say like 80 20. who's not really
liking 20
boo for you that's when you know because
what it's saying to me
is that there are people that are like
such a cheerleader for you
that there's someone that gets triggered
enough to be
such not a cheerleader right in the
stands it's cheering for danica and
they're like
they their fan like they're they're a
fan of let's say i don't know
kyle bush or something they're like yeah
actually probably the other way around
people are not kyle but um
but they'll cheer so for the they'll
cheer against you because they cheer for
someone else
so like kind of puts them in this pinch
position
you know and then you put like so then
to even add another layer of that with
me it's like i'm also not even an
athlete
in this world i'm just a character i'm a
director i'm like
so so for me like you look at like
bellner
or or frasier like there's guys who have
their favorites kind of what you're
describing and they're going to cheer
for one or the other
i'm just the bad guy who's putting all
this stuff the good guy depending on how
you look at it who's putting all the
athletes
through this so um you can either really
like what i'm doing or you can really
dislike
what i'm doing but it's not because of
my physical performance
but you're fit um i mean you're a seal
and you do crossfit every day
what did you think when they came out
with the t-shirts that said dave castro
dick well so that was uh interestingly
that was a sticker i wonder if i have it
in here hold on
i don't know where i have it but when i
was a seal instructor uh
that was the last duty station i had
when i was active duty from 2007-2010 i
was
an instructor in san diego and that's
where josh came through
he came through the training when i was
instructing some of the students made a
mistake here that said dave castro was a
prick
and that got around and like in san
diego there's uh
seal bars and coronado and all over the
place where this sticker was just
everywhere
and uh there's certain training
locations where we would go
um in mississippi or wherever and this
sticker would show up all
all over the place and um it was because
of me being a
dick as an instructor i was a hard
instructor you know i actually look back
at that
time uh and think how i would
do things differently in terms of uh i
was a good instructor
i was really good but i was really
really tough on the students
and um sometimes i think back and
i think i maybe should have tried to
connect a little more but i also
realized as a seal it wasn't
it's a different environment so but
that's another conversation
um so it came from there and josh was
around at that time
so josh was he he was going through the
training when that sticker was out there
then so a number of years later he um
he texted me and said hey can we make a
sticker or a t-shirt
out of that sticker and i was like yeah
go for it
and it became a huge hit like i don't
know how
i don't know one of those shirts i don't
know how they uh how they did with it
but i know
i saw them everywhere and it was pretty
cool i i appreciate
i liked it that wasn't that didn't
bother me at all i thought it was cool
every event i went to someone to be
wearing and want to get a picture with
me
so um i enjoyed that how nice you are
yeah well that's the other thing too
when people meet me especially a lot of
people don't like me
oh you know you it might be different
for you because of the nascar fan but in
terms of me with the crossfit fan
in person i've never had a bad encounter
with any no one like all these people
who say stuff no one's ever come up to
me in person and said
what they would say online to me like
i've never had anyone confront me
that's i you're i'm you're telling my
story
i feel like name so where did you come
like
what was your what were your parents
like what was it like growing up
what was your childhood like where did
you get like from that because it's
rooted in those values
those experiences sometimes it's you
learn it the hard way
and find your own strength and other
times you're taught it
and you're given that strength through
you know your family or your
values so like where where is it coming
from
you know that's an interesting uh a
couple years ago greg
glassman he said to me because your dad
must have been a really um
solid guy and i said yeah why do you say
that he's like because of how you came
out
and i was like that was uh it just made
me reflect a lot on how my dad raised me
and
how our relationship was you know my dad
was a truck driver he had a trucking
company and that's why we ended up at
the ranch
and that large facility there that the
shop was for trucking
and my brother was a sprint car driver i
think i told you before
my dad had a trucking company and he we
were doing well off of it and so he
started a a little race team
and so my brother did sprint car races
all around northern california
he was seven years older than me and i
was uh
so i was a little kid and i i was
drugged to all these races and i hated
it
i really i didn't like the noise and my
brother crashed at all these
uh i thought he was gonna die every time
he went out because he had such nasty
crashes he'd flip over the fences and
stuff like that so um they were
my brother became a truck driver my dad
was a truck driver they were both
mechanics they both had a really
hard work ethic they both worked a lot
and i saw what was going on
and growing up on the ranch i ran around
a lot i was in the hills i played gi joe
i shot i did a lot of stuff like that
and i knew one thing
i knew i didn't want to be a truck
driver and i knew i didn't want to go
into
essentially the the family path of
business so i decided to go to school to
go to college
and i i went to california state
university monterey bay
right down the street in monterey and
but the summer
between graduating high school and going
to college i watched the rock
which was a movie with sean connery and
nicholas cage and in that they had seals
the seals get shot they get killed by
the marines
but they looked really cool you know
they came in in their little underwater
vehicles and they came out of the sewer
with their wetsuits and their
their guns and i was like those guys are
badass and so i started researching and
reading about the seals
and everything i came across was how
their training was the toughest in the
military
and they were the most elite military
unit
so i wondered something crossed my mind
i wondered if i could do that
i said to myself do i have what it takes
to become one of them
so in high school i was on the football
team but i never started
i tried out for the basketball team i
didn't um
i didn't get picked up i can't even say
i got cut because i just didn't get
picked up
and i so i was i did not have a stellar
athletic career in high school
so then there was this this physical
endeavor of becoming a seal
and i was like well i should try this
and i told my parents i wanted
to do it and at first they were like
you're crazy just go to college do
college so i said okay so i stayed in
college for like two months
and i dropped out and said and i went to
a recruiter and i enlisted in the navy
and interestingly that at that time i
said to myself if i don't do this
now i'll never do this and i'll always
wonder what happened what would have my
life been like or what would my life be
if i
did do that i didn't want to have any
regrets i didn't want to have
i didn't want to be 30 40 years old
thinking well one day
once i wanted to be a navy seal i needed
to find out if i could do it and i
needed to
do it then and actually that that kind
of that
train of thought has led me through a
lot of things in life
like okay if i don't do this now you
might not ever do it or you might
a couple years down the road regret
having not tried
or not gone for that or taken a risk
essentially
so i took the risk and um dropped out of
high school
college and enlisted and a few months
later was shipped off
and my parents were really proud of me
at that point in the beginning they
weren't
and um then as i left and went through
the process and
and i made it through the training uh
the the training
is six months long and often times going
through it
people get hurt or rolled back for
performance so you stay there
for a really long time but i was able to
make it through in one
in one iteration which was i was very
fortunate and then so my 20s
that entire time i was stationed mostly
in virginia
and uh that's that's the phase of my
life i don't talk much about
but it's really formative of who i am
now and what i do now
the the the decade 12 years that i was
in the navy
and i don't talk a lot about it because
um you know we were
the silent professional that's how we
were brought up
we were not supposed to talk about what
we did and i really took that to heart
and i uh i was raised in that community
by
guys who were that i really respected
that
kind of beat that mentality into you
that hey you're a navy seal you're not
supposed to
talk about what you do and when i
started working for crossfit
i told greg and tony budding who was
doing a lot of media at that time
i don't want to uh be known as a navy
seal
i don't want you guys to put it out
there and actually the first three years
i was
working for crossfit from 2006 to four
years 2010
i actually was still in the navy so i
told them hey you can't talk about
it don't talk about it so um and
interestingly the 2009 crossfit games
i was deployed to afghanistan planning
the 2009 in 2009 i did a deployment
and i was planning the games and doing
the seminars
and that's like the type of thing i
don't really point to or talk about
anywhere but uh it's kind of kind of
cool kind of unique
and so i really was happy
am happy and proud of the fact that in
this community i still have people who
walk up to me and say hey i just heard
you were a seal
that's really cool thanks thanks for
your service or hey i had no idea you
were seal
that's really something special and the
fact that i
created my own identity in crossfit
independent of being a seal
means a lot to me i didn't use it as a
crutch i didn't lean on it
i'm not you know you never hear people
say dave castro the navy seal
and um i didn't i'm glad it didn't pan
out that way it's you know dave castro
director of the games the crossfit guy
whatever
and i i'm happy with how that turned out
because that was all very deliberate
there are a lot of people now when you
mention their name it's the name someone
saw the navy seal
and um i'm really happy that i didn't
have to go that route
i'm hearing i mean what a story and how
interesting and how much that people
didn't know
and what i'm hearing is just it sounds
like
no i'm hearing so much humility out of
you
and honor yeah i was
if i if i didn't i'm an honor for like
privacy honor for
what is being asked of you and honor for
yourself of following through
and you know interestingly on that um
privacy and
you know that's one of you early on the
hate started towards me
in crossfit as i talked about earlier
and i didn't want that
for my family and i knew eventually if i
did
i i knew eventually would come and so
early on i decided all right i'm going
to keep my family out of the limelight
or
and i'm going to keep my daughters off
off of uh
being out there because
let's say i put my family out there and
had my daughters on instagram and had my
wife on instagram um that's
that's uh selfish of me because they
didn't ask to be put
in this position where they're
they're recognizing the street because
i'm posting them and it's
actually unsafe i didn't want i didn't
want to put them out there
because i often say um you know you look
at jason khalif or rich ronin's kids and
if i were to walk down the street right
now and see those kids
i independent of rich and jason i could
recognize those kids
and say oh that's rich's kid and i don't
think that's a i don't
believe that's a really safe place to be
and so
i uh i'm really happy with how i've also
kept my family
out of the limelight so they can't and
i'm not saying they get attacked but you
know
they might get attacked and i wouldn't
want to have to i wouldn't want to be
the platform for which they're getting
attacked from i wouldn't want to provide
that platform um
people attacked me they might attack
them and it would really that would
really hurt me and i would
it'd be unnecessary so i'm really happy
with how i've
kept that aspect of my life private
because
i do you know in this when you do become
you get a little
popularity in whatever community you
need to have some things
uh some people don't but i do you need
to have some things private and that's
that's where i draw the line
um i don't think you can ever fault
someone for wanting to keep their family
safe
and also be fair right and that's the
honor the honor honoring that you chose
to be in this position but they didn't
choose to be in this position
yeah oh there was something else i was
going to say but i forgot
if uh if i hadn't uh had this
opportunity with crossfit
and and um
[Music]
greg you know in 2006 six seven gave me
this job
i would have stayed in the military for
20 years for sure so i would have done
and i'd be retiring probably i'd retired
about a year ago or so so i really love
what i did in the seal teams and i'm
really proud of it
and i would have done it but this
opportunity with crossfit was something
special and unique and
and not a lot of people had this
opportunity
so i uh i'm proud to do this but i also
would have
been honored to stay in the military and
interestingly there's a
because of the way i've conducted myself
since getting out of the military and
not
call it uh profiting off of being a seal
or leading with that or plastering it
everywhere
there was a seal team where i was
stationed
where they have an annual reunion and
it's
you know it's a they've blacklisted
other people who've gone out and talked
and been very public
with being a seal and what they've done
and they're not no longer there but i'm
still
invited every year i'm still included in
that seal teams
activities and that means a lot to me
that means i've done it right because
here i am a popular figure
and i'm i'm still accepted and and
asked to be involved which which means a
lot makes me proud
in how i've conducted myself post being
a seal virtual high five
thank you um well what
i mean it's been a crazy ride i mean is
that a fair statement
oh man so crazy very crazy so what so
many different levels
yeah for myself included including just
doing fran for the first time in my life
um but what would you
what do you feel like you've learned
about yourself in the process
of this crazy ride what have i learned
about myself in this process i i've
learned
i have a lot of confidence in myself and
i believe
i believe in getting things done and i
believe in
it pushing people past what they believe
is possible i don't even mean physically
but i mean
you know mentally and i mean in terms of
work ethic
i believe there's always a little more
and
and i believe that sometimes you have to
believe in someone more than they
believe in themselves to help
them get further and to ultimately help
your team
and you get further so in that i've also
learned that i push people
sometimes too hard often times not
harder now most
i'm not saying oftentimes not hard
enough most
mostly i push people but it's for a
positive it's for a good outcome
and i oftentimes i do believe they
appreciate it because
at the end of the day they've grown from
it too so
i without trying to sound like
so here's the other thing i also i'm not
a big fan of
preaching and trying to preach in terms
of leadership or preach in terms of
inspiration
i believe people should find most of
that internally
and not have to find it off of a meme or
not have to
listen to it from someone else and if
you can't i think you're uh
in a compromised position but without
trying to sound too much like that i
just really um
i believe in believing in people more
than they sometimes believe in
themselves and that means
pushing them and that means pushing
what's capable
i respect that very much we need people
like you
thank you it's true people
there are people out there that um
are just waiting for you to challenge
them so that they can wake up to
themselves
so
catch some flack or feel uncomfortable
or might not seem like always
the easygoing fun guy
at times we need you
interestingly i just uh this just kind
of connected that also happens in the
workouts
i program in the open or in the games so
you think about some of the stuff i've
programmed where
in the open people getting their first
bar muscle ups people getting their
snatching 100 pound dumbbell for the
first time at regionals or games
so that that kind of having talked
through it
plays out in the programming we push the
athletes we push the community
further than they often believe they are
ready to be pushed and that's kind of
cool
the open special and cool like that look
at this i mean look at how many people
are like reveling and breaking down and
crying
and getting emotional about their
realizing their potential it's a
beautiful thing to see
yeah for sure the spiral that that
creates from just like
doing a bar muscle up and then stepping
into their job or into
their relationship or into their life
with more confidence as well because
it can't help but infiltrate every
little bit of you
and you give that yeah
that's cool so
final question since i know you like to
challenge people
backwards double unders just throwing it
out there hey so you know who the first
backward double under person
in the community was the first like
person doing it no no no no not
backwards
josh bridges oh so one of the first
open workouts we ever um one of the
first open workouts we had with double
unders
he did and he submitted a video and he
did all his double unders backwards
and we were like can you do them well
can you do them
oh i can do a hundred plus backwards in
a row
yeah crazy you guys should have a
backward double under off
so he said he told me he's like that's
how i learned how to do it i uh
i just learned how to do them backwards
and that's how we well and we decided at
the time
uh we didn't know what to do but we said
okay we're not going to take them we're
only going to accept forward double
unders
by the way saved me from competing
any level locally or anything because i
know
i can't do forward double unders so i'm
like that's a pretty basic movement
so now you got to learn it you got to
practice
you got to try to look like a whipped
whip
learning them backwards is hard enough
you know how you learn them forward you
just do single lenders single owners is
the key get really good
it's funny because i've seen people who
can murder double unders who are great
at double unders
and then you ask them just to do single
jumps and they don't have them at all
but single jumps are really the
foundation for for
double unders and everything else i i
actually did a instagram live workout
and um
i tested out a new rep scheme on
everybody which actually worked out fine
and um it was jump rope was the first
minute and every every round
you added one minute and one movement up
to eight and uh
those eight minutes of jumping rope and
so i would incorporate some double
unders in there but i was doing some
forward and i tried i did like
one double forward tripped up and i'm
like yeah that's why i
can't do it and now i've wasted so much
time on the clock for the minute that
i'm gonna have to do double unders
backwards for the whole rest of the time
but um i i i
let's face it i'm too old you can't
teach an old dog new tricks
you can learn you can learn you're right
i could i'm just doesn't i just don't
care
yes exactly and then it saves me from
competing
um yes well thank you so much dave this
has been you know thank you for you know
your vulnerability
the honesty and um you know the stories
and wow you know you've changed a lot of
lives with
everything from your challenging
challenging programming to just the
presentation of crossfit
maybe the other maybe the very last
question is
can you please just do the open
announcements again
like i didn't even i'm not i'm sorry
this is the truth i didn't watch them
after you stopped neither did i
and it's confusing because they're all
over the world and i'm like what
language am i in
so i'd really like you to do i
really i really enjoy that month and
actually we would be doing it right now
wouldn't we
be over yeah february march but now it's
in
that's right end of the yeah so
you think about it can you contemplate
i'll contemplate
thank you thanks danica appreciate the
time this is fun
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more
please click on the subscribe button